okay so what exactly is a Radian well we
already know about how to measure angles
and degrees we know there's 360 degrees
in a circle so all the Radian is it's
just another measure of rotation and
what you can think about is you can
think about this is like a spinner like
say this this is like your spinner and
you're spinning it and then say it
rotates to here and then you can see
that this arc that it you know traverses
we're gonna call s so this is like our
arc length this is our radius because
you can see this is kind of like a
circle and what we want to do to find an
angle and Radian measure is we want to
use this formula here it's the ratio of
the arc length divided by the radius so
a quick example would be say for example
you had an arc like this okay so an arc
is just like a part of a circle right
and say that this radius here was like
one-inch say that this arc length if you
were to like straighten that out it was
two inches then we would say okay the
ratio of the arc length divided by the
radius would be two inches divided by
one inches so we would call this two
radians okay so you're probably still
wondering you know well what is a Radian
well let's take it one step further so
we know that say for example we draw a
circle like this 360 degrees that's we
understand degrees but if we use our
formula this arc length all the way
around a circle is actually the
circumference of the circle and we know
the formula for the circumference of a
circle it's two PI R and we know that
the radius of courses R and if we again
take the ratio of the arc length which
is 2 PI R that's once around the circle
divided by the radius which is R you can
see that those ours are cancelling and
so now what we have is two pi radians
represents 360 degrees so that's our way
of converting now to make it a little
bit simpler if we just go half a
revolution so if we just go halfway
around the circle 180 degrees 180
degrees is equal to PI radians okay so
now we're starting to get a little bit
better feel so we kind of say 180
degrees is the same as in pi radians so
we can use what we call a conversion fat
and that's going to be either a hundred
and eighty over PI or PI over 180
because remember these are equal to one
another anything divided by itself is
one so by multiplying say for example if
we had 45 degrees and we want to know
you know what is that in radians we're
gonna multiply it by this conversion
factor here hi over 180 degrees notice
how that degree symbol in the numerator
cancels with the degree symbol in the
denominator and when we multiply
horizontally across we get 45 PI over
180 and you can see that 45 goes in here
once 45 goes in here 4 times so we're
left with 1 PI over 4 if you just say PI
over 4 and then this is now in radians
notice we don't have that degree symbol
there anymore now if we wanted to go the
other direction where we're given an
angle in radians like 2 PI over 3 notice
there's not a degree symbol there we're
going to use this conversion factor 180
degrees for every pi radians so now we
can see that the PI is in the
denominator cancel 2 pi radians in the
numerator if we multiply horizontally
across this is 360 divided by 3 which is
120 degrees and now you've converted you
know from radiance into degrees so
you're still probably wondering well you
know Mario what exactly is a Radian well
if you want to know just one Radian it's
going to be approximately 57 degrees
okay not exactly
okay just approximately to the nearest
degree but again what we're doing here
is we're learning how to think in terms
of radians radians just an angle measure
it's just that rotation and amount of
that rotation and it's just a different
unit so let's take it one step further
now we've converted the units from
degrees to radians radians to degrees
how do we graph an angle in radians in
what's called standard position so
standard position is you want to put
your initial ray you're starting ray
along at positive x-axis if you rotate
counterclockwise that's a positive angle
if you rotate clockwise it's a negative
angle so it's kind of like a spinner if
we spin this 7 PI over 6 radians where
do we end up well an easy way to think
about this okay to start thinking in
terms of radians is to come
earth descent 2 and a mixed number like
this is like an improper fraction 6 goes
into 7 once with 1 left over so we're
really looking at 1 in 1 6 pi I just
kind of rewrote it a little bit we know
that pi is like a half revolution it's
like 180 degrees we were talking about
that here but now we're going an
additional 1/6 of Pi so imagine dividing
this up into 1 2 3 4 5 6 equal pieces
this half revolution we're just going
one part out of 6 so we went 1 pi plus
1/6 pi this here is going to be our
terminal ray where it terminates our
stops and that's going to be our angle
in radians in standard position so
that's how much rotation we're looking
at here now let's look at another
example using a negative angle so see
the negative 8 PI over 3 again you still
want to start along that positive x-axis
that's your initial ray or it initiates
or starts the only differences we're
going to be going this direction
clockwise and let's convert this into a
mixed number so 3 goes into 8 twice with
2 left over so we're really looking at
negative 2 and 2/3 pi so we know that
negative 1 pi would be here that's a
half revolution we said 2 pi was like
one full revolution and now we're going
another 2/3 pi so if we were to go PI
we'd be right here we're just going 2/3
of the way which is approximately right
there so that's our rotation but in
terms of radians now the next thing you
want to understand our what are called
reference angles what is a reference
angle well we already talked about how
you know when you spin this if you don't
in it and one of the axes you're gonna
either end up in the first second third
or fourth quadrants right you could end
up right on that axis but let's just
talk about right now for the sake of
this example you're gonna end up here
here here or here wherever you end up
you want to drop a perpendicular
straight down to the x-axis never to the
y-axis always to the action remember
that so for example this one we would go
down to here this one we would go up to
here this one we were go up to the
x-axis like so so some people refer this
as like a bowtie all right kind of looks
like a bowtie but you look at that angle
between the x-axis and the terminal ray
that's what's called our
for its same thing here this would be a
reference angle this would be a
reference angle this would be a
reference angle it's always gonna be
between 0 and 90 or 0 and PI over 2 if
you're thinking in terms of radians so
for example here we know we spun around
it doesn't matter how many times you go
around me you know around revolve here
it what it matters is where you end up
you drop a perpendicular to the x-axis
and you look at that angle in between
that terminal ray and the x-axis well
you can see in this example we went an
additional two thirds of pi so you can
see it's going to take another 1/3 pi to
get back to that x-axis which means that
our reference angle is PI over 3 or 1/3
PI so you're probably saying well what
is the significance of that Mario well
this ties into what you learn about when
you're working with common trig values
using the unit circle and I talked about
that in the video right there follow me
over to that video and we'll talk more
about the unit circle in radians as well
as in degrees I'll see you over in that
video